Film Courage: Do you think that teaching screenwriting
or these books or whatever is selling false
hope?
This has been one criticism of what we’ve
seen [comments in videos and our channel]
and I don’t see why this would be selling
false hope?
If [writing] is something someone enjoys and
they love the process of creating?
Al Watt, Author, Screenwriter and Founder
of L.A. Writers' Lab: Okay I love this!
I believe that my job as a writing teacher
is to facilitate writers in finding the story
that lives within them and stay out of the
result.
In other words when you get into the result
that’s when you get tripped up.
That’s when you don’t really write from
your heart.
That’s when you don’t write something
that’s actually going to be meaningful to
other people and so I always think of writing
as a two-tiered process.
The first tier is you have to write if for
yourself and then the second tier is once
you’ve written it for yourself, once you’ve
written that stuff where you’re like “Oh
my gosh, I can’t show this to anybody.
It’s way too personal.”
Even if it’s fiction, especially if it’s
fiction, you’ve got to have some skin in
the game.
You’ve got to be invested in this thing
that you are writing.
You’ve got to let go of this idea that “Is
it going to sell?”
You can’t…I remember when I wrote my first
novel.
I woke up one day and I was like I’ve been
writing for a long time.
I was making a living as a stand-up comic.
But I’d been writing for a long time and
I hadn’t sold anything and I thought well
you know let me do the math here.
Clearly I must be a mediocre writer if I’ve
been writing for this long and I haven’t
sold anything.
So what I’m going to do is I’m going to
stop writing for the marketplace (whatever
that is) and I’m going to write something
for myself.
I’m going to write something that really
means something to me and I wrote a story
that I wrote really quick.
I wrote a novel called Diamond Dogs and got
it through this lawyer friend of mine and
got it to an agent.
She auctioned it a week later for a ridiculous
amount of money and then it becomes a best-seller
and it won a bunch of awards and it was the
first time I realized that don’t know anything.
And when I try and … you know I always say
my idea or my story is never the whole story…my
idea who is going to like this or who is going
to like that is…I can’t control the result.
None of us have any control over the result.
But what we do have control over is understanding
that we’re all unique, we all have something
valuable to say and I really believe that
as a writer and a writing teacher.
So I want to help writers.
I can’t predict…some of my students have
gone on to become best-selling authors, show
runners, A-list screenwriters.
I didn’t know who they were going to be.
But the ingredient that I think is most valuable
isn’t talent whatever that is.
It’s a willingness to learn, it’s a humility,
it’s a willingness to be curious about the
story that lives within you.
It’s the humility to put it on the page
while staying out of the result.
That’s really hard for people.
That’s the really challenging test.
Being a writer is a marathon, it’s not a
sprint.
And if you expect immediate results, you might
not stay in the game long enough to experience
the fruits of your labor.